يجد مناهضو التطعيم نجاحًا في شن حملة
على الكلمة الرئيسية في مجال الحرية ،
الصحفية العلمية تارا هالي ، نظرت عن
كثب إلى هذه الظاهرة وهي تكتب
في نيويورك تايمز ، فهذه هي اللحظة
التي تنتظر فيها الحركة المناهضة للقاح
إحصائية مقلقة تشير
إلى
أننا الأكثر تطورًا  من
المؤكد أن دولة في العالم ستقع في المركز الأخير بين
دول مجموعة السبع فيما يتعلق بالتطعيمات وفي
جميع أنحاء البلاد يتم تطعيم 63 في المائة فقط ،
وهو ما
يختلف عن أوروبا حيث يوجد
80 في المائة ككل وهنا في المملكة المتحدة 77
لذا كل هذا لنقول
لماذا
وما الذي اكتشفت أنه السبب
الأكثر ضررًا
لنقص التطعيم هذا ،
فهناك العديد من الأسباب ولكن السبب المهيمن
هو
المعلومات المضللة المكثفة التي يتم
توزيعها منذ فترة طويلة جدًا
وأنا
أعمل على متابعة  حركة مناهضة للقاحات
لمدة عقد من الزمان ، وخاصة
بدءًا من عام 2015 ، شهدنا تحولًا حيث
كانت المعلومات المضللة مستمرة ولكنها
كانت تتزايد  لقد بدأ نوعًا ما
في الاندماج مع خطاب
الحزب الجمهوري حيث
رأينا نشطاء مناهضين للقاحات
يتخذون صرخة الحرية هذه قائلين إن لدي
الحرية في تحديد ما يحدث
لجسدي ، ولدي الحرية في تحديد
ما يحدث لأولادي
و  سواء أعطيتهم اللقاح أم لا
وكان ذلك منسجمًا جيدًا مع
الخطاب القائم والحزب الجمهوري
للضغط من أجل
التحرر من
طغيان الحكومة وأشياء أخرى
، فأنت تعرف حركة حفل الشاي التي
دفعت إلى رواية الحرية هذه
تم دمجها
ومكنت النشطاء المناهضين للقاح من
جلب الكثير من المشرعين أه الجمهوريين
إلى جانبهم والقادة
إلى جانبهم
إذا لم تنجح السخرية
كما رأينا في حفل الشاي ولم
يكن الأمر كذلك.  شيء رائع للسخرية من الناس ،
كيف يمكنك
فعلاً إيصال الرسالة الصحيحة ،
فأنا هناك ، سأخبرك أولاً
بما لا يجب فعله ، لم تذكر السخرية
ولكن شيئًا آخر لا يفيدك
القيام به هو تضخيم الرسائل التي
تسمعها من النشطاء المناهضين للقاحات حتى لو كان
ذلك من أجل القول إن هذا
جنون بدلاً من ذلك ، فأنت بحاجة إلى التركيز على
قول المعلومات الدقيقة ولكن في
الحقيقة أحد الأشياء التي نعتقد أنها من
الأشياء التي نعتقد  الأعمال التي لا
تعمل بالشكل الذي نتمناه هي إعطاء
الأشخاص حقائق نحتاجها لإعطاء الناس
حقائق تمامًا ولكن الحقائق وحدها لا
تكفي لتغيير عقول الناس ، لذلك
هناك طريقتان مختلفتان للنظر إلى
هذا على المستوى الكلي الذي نحتاجه  أن يكون
هناك العديد من الأشخاص في الحزب الجمهوري
المؤيدين للقاح الذين تم
تطعيمهم والذين يعرفون قيمة
اللقاحات ولدينا الكثير منهم يتحدثون ،
لكننا نحتاج إلى المزيد منهم يتحدثون بصوت
عالٍ ونريدهم أن يتحدثوا إلى
وإخبارهم بأنني تلقيت
هذا اللقاح ، هذا اللقاح آمن ،
أريدك أن تكون آمنًا أيضًا ، لذا فنحن بحاجة إلى
نماذج فعلية لما يسمونه بالرسل الموثوق بهم
ينقلون هذه الفكرة لنقل
هذه الرسالة المهمة إلى  هناك
شيء واحد لواحد عندما تتحدث إلى
شخص ما يتحدث ، لدينا جميعًا القدرة على
التحدث إلى الأشخاص من حولنا الذين لم يتم
تطعيمهم ولكن ما نحتاج إلى فعله هو أن
نبدأ بالاستماع إليهم واسألهم لماذا
أنت قلق  ما الذي يقلقك ما الذي
يخيفك
والاستماع إلى ما يقولونه ثم
حاول اكتشاف ما تحت ذلك ما
تعرفه ما هو القلق بشأن الخصوبة ،
لذلك تخشى
أن يؤثر هذا على خصوبتك على المدى الطويل ،
فأنت تخشى ذلك  ستفقد
السيطرة على قدرتك على التحكم في
قدرتك على إنجاب طفل تعرفه ثم
تبدأ في استخدام نوع ما ، أنا أعرف
الطريقة السقراطية ولكنك تعلم أن طرح
الأسئلة عليهم جيدًا ، هل أدركت أن
العديد من النساء يموتن أثناء الحمل  هل أدركت خلال فترة التوفين
أن الطفل يمكنه الحصول على
أجسام مضادة فعلية أه عندما تفعل
ذلك ، هل أدركت أن دراسة أجريت على
أكثر من 30000 شخص لم تجد
خطرًا أكبر للولادة المبكرة أو أي مشاكل
في اللقاح ، ولكن أنت تسأل
منهم هؤلاء كيو  لكن بعد ذلك
تعود للاستماع إليهم ويجب
أن يكون حوارًا ولا
يحدث في جلسة واحدة كثير من الناس
لا يتحلى بالصبر لأنهم
يشعرون أنه لا فائدة وأن
هناك  تشير إلى أنها تعمل
ولكنها تستغرق وقتًا ويجب أن
تتفاعل معهم حقًا